[Music]
we have taken a look at the reproductive
system in males now before moving on to
the process of fertilization we need to
understand the place where this process
takes place yes I am referring to the
female reproductive system the site of
overproduction fertilization and the
uterus are all a part of the female
reproductive system let's have a look at
this important system in this video do
you remember where we began studying the
male reproductive system
yes it was the site of sperm production
similarly we will begin learning from
the site of production of the egg cell
or simply the ovum so the journey begins
from these oval structures called the
ovaries one ovary on either side did you
notice that the ovaries are connected to
these two black structures but they're
not connected directly if we look at it
carefully we find that there are
finger-like projections which connect
the two these finger-like projections
are very important for receiving the
ovum when released from the ovaries but
do they have a scientific name yes these
finger-like projections are called the
fembra ii the fembra ii helped to hold
the ovum released and also helped to
sweep it to the tubes present ahead but
why does the ovum require the sweeping
activity cantered travel on its own no
it can't
unlike the motile sperm the ovum is non
motile it cannot move until it is pushed
or swept by some other cells now these
two black structures that we are
referring to since a long time also have
a scientific name they are called as the
fallopian tubes and what do you think
will be their importance let me guess is
it that they connect the ovaries to the
uterus yes that is definitely one
important function but more important
than this is the fact that the fallopian
tubes are the site of fertilization yes
it is the Philip
tubes where the sperms are able to
fertilize the ovum and from here the
zygote starts dividing and grows into an
embryo now where will this embryo go
further needless to say the uterus
we know that the uterus commonly
referred to as the womb is the site of
development of a baby and when the
growth of the baby is completed it comes
out of the mother's body through the
vagina do we know what the vagina is it
is basically a small passage that opens
to the exterior it is the site where
sperms are received in the female's body
on the other hand the same passage is
used for passing the baby out of the
body during childbirth now that you've
learned both the reproductive systems
can you tell me which one is more
complex than the other one just think
for a moment if you think it is the male
reproductive system and you may be wrong
yes the female reproductive system is
more complex the system is designed for
the complete process of fertilization as
well as the growth and the development
of the baby that is a reason why it is
slightly more complicated compared to
the male reproductive system this was
just an overview of how the female
reproductive system is we would get to
know how every organ in the system works
efficiently when we understand the
process of fertilization and the
development process of the embryo in
detail for that you need to watch our
next video
[Music]